well there is also heartbreak over the
murder of christina grimmie the boy star
who was gunned down over the weekend
oddly enough also in Orlando she
finished in the top three after being
coached by Adam Levine and her career
was just taking off trapeze are pouring
in from some of the biggest music stars
as police take the motive of the man who
shot her point-blank this video of
Christina would viral within hours of
her death after a show I like to stay
really long afterwards and meet everyone
and hear the story and it was after her
concert Friday while signing autographs
and meeting fans when Christina was shot
and killed by a deranged gunman
Selena Gomez who signed Christina to a
contract when she was 14 broke down
during a tribute on Saturdays
according to police Kevin James
Louisville came to the concert armed
with two handguns and a hunting knife
there were no metal detectors at the
arena as to why Louisville did it the
investigation continues my brother's
actually currently on tour with me right
now
he's my tour manager guitar player he
wears many hats and he's very supportive
and it was Christina's brother Marcus
who threw himself on the gunman and
wrestled him to the ground
loyal then shot himself during the
scuffle today Marcus posted that his
sister's coach on the voice Adam Levine
will pay for her funeral
Adam was such a fan of Christina if I
could post AddThis about her christina
was a natural a gifted talent that comes
along so rarely she was taken from us
too soon this is yet another senseless
act of extreme violence